- [Narrator] Welcome to
Vác, a small town in Hungary
by the river Danube.
(concert piano music)
Wait, where is that sound coming from?
Where is it, where is it?
Is it here?
(bicycle bell chime)
OK, getting closer.
Wow!
That's a tall piano!
(piano music)
Steel frames and Aloe Vera plants.
Some tools and half a piano?
Where have we ended up?
- Welcome to my workshop.
- [Narrator] Oh! And you are?
- My name is David Klavins,
and I'm a piano builder.
During my education,
I was told that pianos
are made only one way;
that's the way that you see
all over the planet today.
And I was very dissatisfied
with such an answer,
of course, so I began
to wonder how the piano
could be improved or made different.
I wanted to hear the sound,
which I had in my head.
I had an imagination of
sound that didn't exist.
(deep bell chords)
- [Narrator] By all means,
David, show us your pianos.
- OK. Come with me.
This is one of my pianos, the Una Chorda.
(melodic piano playing)
A small Una Chorda is
essentially the softest sounding,
because we have only one string per note.
- [Narrator] That's interesting!
What do you have next?
- This is the Concert Una Chorda.
(blissful piano melody)
The concert size Una
Chorda has a fuller sound
because it's 2 meters
tall and 2.20 meters wide.
This is my biggest piano-the
vertical concert grand
of 4.70 meters.
(melodic piano playing)
In my view, the 4.70
piano must be vertical
and not horizontal, in
order to emanate the sound
directly to the public.
People need to hear the best quality sound
in concerts, and they have
not heard it until now.
The concert piano has double strings from
the first bass note,
which no other piano has.
It makes it the fullest sounding piano
on the planet.
- [Narrator] By my math,
at 15 feet, it's the
tallest on the planet, too.
And how does one start
making a piano this tall?
- First challenge is to get
a place where you can do it.
Like this one.
It is quite an act to get the
piano out of the workshop.
It is only possible by hiring cranes.
It typically takes two hours
only getting through the door.
Assembling the piano
again, it's different than
every piano, because slight differences in
dimensions can ask for
slight different treatments.
There's a lot of handcrafting involved.
(charming piano music)
Essentially, I love to
create new and beautiful
music, and building pianos
and creating beautiful
music is a very important
task these days in particular,
to counter the evil on the planet by
something very positive.